all right love you welcome you to this
is the 18th session
Yakima's June and this series on
speculative fiction from worlds
speculative fiction where what we're
looking at is in for narrative worlds
but usually also philosophical themes
and so this time we're looking at not
sure if it's pronounced eating or I on I
actually looked it up online and people
said both no I'm just going to say p.m.
because that's easy for me to remember
Ian banks and these culture series books
I've got two of them here as to some
other ones around big thick novels which
represented a bit of a problem for me in
part because the normal tack that I
would take focusing on with a plot and
characters you can't do that when you're
talking about this this air to the
universe in part because it's all about
I suppose if there's a character to
culture massive organization but
trillions of human beings spread out
over millennia saw plenty good yeah
bubble sounds like read the pool yeah
well so this is another one of the
suggestions I'm really glad that you
suggested it because I really enjoyed
what have a chance to read I waited for
the first two novels unfortunately but
it's good because we have a pool of
expertise on some of the others here I
don't have as many notes prepared as
usual you know the timeline as usual and
banks died pretty recently so we'll talk
a bit about this biography I've got some
interesting quotes where he's talking
about the culture series I thought that
would be particularly useful for talking
about his politics and and what he
thinks about science fiction in general
and then I've got six teams that I
thought would particularly stand out in
his war
we can certainly talk about others and
so one of them is this whole idea of
post-scarcity society and technology
leading us to that particularly timely
because there's a lot of discussion
right now about everything we were
actually just talking about this before
we started about what AI can can be
delegated to do you know in terms of our
crafts and our skills and we do ever
think about this pressing question of
what are we going to do and there isn't
work for a lot of the population how are
we going to handle that into society so
there's one thing genetic enhancement
and what that does to the human
condition I think there's another
interesting theme when you get people
who can produce their own drugs in their
in their brains you know that's very
different and it's hopefully about AI
minds and then the other types of AI the
drones and this whole you know you might
say whole new set of beings created to
be part of that society they have
certain you know rights and expectations
that's an interesting theme on the
politics in the culture itself which we
don't actually need to see that much of
we see mostly what's happening at the
periphery of it but we have to care a
bit about what's going on you know in
their deliberation with how they split
offer to each other that's another one
and then I was really struck by this
this dynamic that you see this need for
what they call the contact group which
are the people that are doing the dirty
work in assets right the stuff dealing
with the people who are not part of
Utopia dealing with all this and that
especially special circumstances which
is very military intelligence arm and
then one of the things that came up in
player games that I thought was
particularly interesting is this notion
of how games interface with reality and
they're not sustainable in a virtual
reality stuff you know escape
into a matrix or something like that in
this there's this game that that is
deciding who gets to be in charge and
it's supposed to be sort of fair game
and replicating certain conditions and
then you know the Kree advisors to the
Past are electing of the story that we
tell about a lot of different things and
turns out that's not actually the case
but there's this an interesting
corollary there so those are the themes
I thought I think we'll probably had a
lot more you know sort of what about
Deb's would have up depth and then in
some of the other cases in part because
I'm much more at the amateur level when
it comes to this particular narrative
universe so let's talk about very
briefly about his biography see that you
know Gordon 54 so if you were around
today which he was until recently he
would be in his 60s he's born in
Scotland and I don't really know
Scottish geography or culture enough to
make sense of the references to east and
west Scotland and why the move made such
a big difference but but it you know
that's one of the kinks actually does
talk about the fact that you're moving
from this side to the outside and he
goes to the University of Stirling which
which eventually gave about honorary
degree very nice thing to do I suppose
he gets a BA in English philosophy and
psychology so he's already spread out
over a number of different fields I've
been in worse through a bunch of
different jobs some of them you know
like collecting garbage
some of them working in a law office
just you know the things that kind of
fill unemployment he's writing
constantly and in that early part of his
career like quite a few of the people
we've talked about he's getting a lot of
rejection letters yeah okay which seems
to be that the case for a lot of
innovative
of science fiction and fantasy and he
stuck with it keeps writing and
eventually he publishes this book the
wasp factory in 84 which I hadn't read
have any of you read it okay but it's
the chance to read it
yeah from what I read about it seems
like quite a ride doesn't it a
distinctly British grotesque a style I
was told yeah any humor kind of secure
and also more psychological stuff yeah I
wonder this you know one of the people
we talked about last year was Mervyn
Peake and I'm wandering good morning
yeah the person who similar introduced
me to it like two Gormenghast okay oh
well I don't want the interesting that
so he lets his first book people it is
quite successful with that you meet this
his first eventually first wife Annie
becomes a full-time writer they moved to
Sagar Sean and then you notice like it
he's like clockwork just reading out a
book a year most years the first book in
the culture series and I put the ones in
the culture series in dark so that he
can tell where they are is in 87 that's
considered flood us miss polkas remember
let's scrub earlier and play your games
comes out you know fairly soon after
that and interestingly from what I found
out about his writing process he wants
to get the books done fairly quickly so
that he has plenty of time to not write
to do other things of that I think he
liked the pace of one book a year
because he could you know get his
writing done and maybe she's really
lucky in two or three months maybe six
months and then the rest of time he can
drive around in his cars he collected
you know sports cars and fancy cars and
things like that and drink whiskey and
smoke cigars and in general enjoy
himself know what sounded like pretty
good life actually writing at the time
of them doing doing fun stuff directly
and you see the year after year he
produces four
Voki start winning awards there's there
some back and forth in his personal
relationship with Annie he breaks up
with her gets back together when their
marries her eventually during separate
down the line
and they're going to separate after he
thinks that the woman who would become
his his late life Adelle behaves a
relationship with her and you notice
that Yeltsin well I didn't put too much
of the political stuff in here but he is
involved in quite a few causes he's on
the left and he for instance opposes
apartheid and he took involved with some
things have to do the palace the
Palestinians and the Israelis
he also winds up you know for example
resigning his membership of a Scotch
malt whisky Society after after there's
a commercial takeover anything he
forgets that he can't came to get Tony
Blair and peached after the Gulf they're
getting in the Gulf War and he's going
along pretty well it was cancer that did
have been nvm he has a gallbladder
cancer and I don't think this awful lot
at this point they can do about that
alright that's one of those so like
pancreatic or it's going to cancer yeah
I'm either down the line you know it's
one of the things we can talk about this
culture on the line hopefully all of
this stuff gets sorted out but it's just
talking about that to go awry well but
which diseases will go next or a lot of
the paper to get there and get all
screwed man yeah they're going good
cause when you generation from now
different story yeah I mean you know
down Rosen they don't let the progress
that's been made just with our lifetimes
my my dad died when I was 11 so in the
80s and during that time we spent a lot
of time
hospital because EDM they never figured
out what it was we went to the Mayo
Clinic and they do lots of tests and
stuff like that
any think about well it was today maybe
they would have like figured it out like
that in who knows there's so many things
where 30 years ago you worked out you
were goner and now you know things are
are treatable with others of the things
that will still can be pretty quickly
now well so that's kind of a good segue
into talking about this this universe
that he creates which is the universe
that right now fits into because in a
storyline it's overlapping with the time
period that we're living at an earth is
discussed a little kick what in some of
the stories just tangentially so I've
got these quotes and I think we could
start with these because these give us
kind of a good picture one is the first
one in the view is asked to give sort of
a summary of what's going on with this
this culture and here he's talking about
it's utopia enteric turistic but I think
we should probably practice this by
saying so the culture is spreading
throughout the galaxy it doesn't control
the entire galaxy but it controls a lot
of it and they have gone so far along
with technology that they're no longer
just found planets they create these
these other living what would you call
the habitations you know like you can
the ring around a Sun there's there's
spheres what else oh there there's a
whole bunch of different things orbital
yeah yeah and then if you do something
like that
pankot of people it and they don't all
have to live on top of each other look
extinguish you know some people like but
a lot of people don't and and you can
have all sorts of you know green space
and oceans and whatever they like on
these these places and in fact they do
so that's that's a important thing to
keep in mind so we could the culture is
a self-consciously altruistic
sopia post-scarcity human-machine
civilization it's already big mouthful
right there existing as an important and
influential but far from dominant part
of the greater galactic meta society
it's a mongrel society formed about
9,000 years from seven or it ago from
the southern area humanoid species game
there ax it exists now which was
discovered in 1977 see and fully
documented and we're being left alone
for the moment as part of a control
group so the cultures of functioning
utopia or as close to anything remotely
human can get to utopia and it's
dedicated to interfering in less
developed civilizations for their own
good natural but you've got Italy
utopian aspect of things where you also
get this is kind of cultural imperialism
going on at the same time as well right
because everybody always knows better
from there interfere with somebody else
so they said that it's a you know even
date you the mind bogglingly extents of
a comprehensive range of statistics and
other evidence should you question
whether this is a good idea because
they're doing all the research they got
to people are they've been what would he
call it that the number is on their side
because they're Dickens throw you know a
hundred thousand people at this one
problem to work at it and a whole bunch
of a is to work on it as well other
people will actually want to work it
sort of says it's been doing this for
most of those nine thousand years it's
the main thing that does it beyond
itself and it claims to have gotten very
good at mostly and so here the key thing
mostly the culture consists of tens of
trillions of people and machines having
a brilliant guilt-free time that would
be boring to write about and read about
so I tend to concentrate on the
interesting stuff happening and the
edges were the exciting adventures and
big explosions tend to like this one
give a big explosion a lot like supper
get an action movie it
and so he's what he's created there is
you know for narrative
well it's like a gigantic playground
anything is possible
so I'm going actually ask them in
another interview did you get some of
this stuff in records file of me you
know singularity and so not think about
that before you have the air traffic I
just try to fix it on my own but it's
it's an interesting business of
interesting problems because so all of
the stuff that that we we tend to
struggle with like mortgages and paying
your taxes you know what what the
economy is going to look like ten years
from now and should I go to school or
not go to school oh that's that's all
taken care of you can be anything you
want and you can even be things you
don't have a real aptitude for because
though there's no consequences to your
failings right so if I don't have a lot
of usable camels I can still be a singer
and hang out in cafe Haysom and people
can come listen to me perhaps ironically
you know and there's all those karaoke
absolutely committed for whether they
are we might complain I suppose right
we're looking at some places but you
know so they're there but then the
question is well okay so what do you do
sorry you know the the way in which it
gets talked about quite a bit is the
cultures hedonistic civilization is
devoted to pleasures and if you think
about it we didn't have to do all the BS
that we have to do in order to make a
living and original I can provide for
kids and keep the government off our
back and all the other stuff is we need
to do how do we spend our time
what would we enjoy that's that's the
key question that a lot of these people
have to figure out and it's you know it
doesn't seem like a hard question for
those of us who actually do work a lot
because we don't we don't spend a lot of
time thinking on order our pleasures but
if you did have like 24/7 you know okay
do whatever you want anything that you
want to hand we can provide to you
eventually you
start to have to struggle if it's
figured what with me what do I actually
like you know I mean think about like
food right so if if you could have
whatever you wanted to eat and there
weren't any real consequence like
getting fat or getting being bad for
your your things or things like that
what would you select you know and so
given my own lobster every night lobster
is boring pretty quick you know there's
like so many things you can give a
lobster you know start liking dinners
with desserts and an uncle used to do
that you sure the best part first but
you could have meal with her just
desserts
okay eventually you're going to get a
Morgan don't you think I mean you know I
think you're reacting in a sense that
this is like a switch but it happens
gradually yeah
what do you know and well the reunions
that we are already yeah I mean yeah
we're looking at this or any other world
as sort of a open the blinds or whatever
it all works immediately and
significantly different and challenging
and yeah how do they do these things but
we are already doing these things
graduate choices of food or whatever
yeah and choices of Transportation any
machine things that are done for sit out
on machines but I mean that there is a
you know we're not dwelling in the field
is maybe yeah it'll be much different as
our grandparents opening our
great-grandparents open the door and
seeing what we are saying yeah we know
this is going to sound kind of silly
this example but I remember encountering
tacos and they were like all the great
tacos they were just like you know
Ortega
taco shells with in foods with same four
ingredients
the meat cheese tomatoes and some
lettuce at a nice
departing for the neighbor when I was
like 10 years old and it was my boy we
never had anything like that
yeah weekend man spaghetti and we have
this and that and my mom is a great cook
but you know tacos like took the
neighborhood by storm it was a new thing
and now of course you know we look back
at that and I pulled oh they're very
good tacos here okay what were you
thinking but it was you know like you
said it I guess that metaphor pulling
the blinds that's really a good one look
but I think another point too is that we
place a higher value or greater value on
something that we invest from ourselves
oh when we get a lot of things
conveniently or quickly you see it
wasn't it's great but we're losing
something that we're not maybe taking
note up I think and yeah I would support
short time in East Africa and were like
four quarters can speak English right
Rose no anyhow one of the I encourage
some questioning and have been one of
the the ladies said is it true kind of
hash tones you know that in in America
that that wives and mothers they have
machines to make bread you know why
would they want him it residually had a
fundamental purpose in providing
nutrition a hands-on you know for their
families again and they could not
conceive why you would not want that you
know yeah I mean it just has an example
I mean no I think that's completely
right that's one of the issues that that
societies like that eventually has to
grapple with because it's not just the
sense of producing bread to sell to
somebody else or something like that it
this gives me my my purpose and it's
like you say putting something of
yourself into it right yeah into keeping
where's your meaning and purpose at the
individual as a group as a culture yeah
and so when you have a lot of these
other things that also Dennard um some
that
meaning and purpose and then you turn to
what would call hedonism and then maybe
one does it slip back and yeah hey all
this is without meaning and value and
purpose you need to do something get out
that I invest in I have some skin in the
game and I can get something back at
participating in the process yeah the
homeowner that went over that I would
say that's probably one the driving
points of player games is the lead in
there is basically lost it's not lines
interesting anymore and definitely is
given this opportunity to do something
that's far outside his comfort zone
because yes everything has become
commonplace yeah yeah yeah and if you
wants to see his friends in the halfway
across this world oh he's given up
underground magnetic car here they're a
half-hour later as opposed to taking
stick eaters or however long it will
take to travel to another article well
you know what the whole thing about the
contact group those are all people who
are choosing to be on the fringes of the
culture dealing with other civilizations
because there's something happening and
then they can they can do something
there's also there some of them are kind
of thrill seekers too so there's a
chance you could get killed which is
probably not going to happen in the rest
of the culture is no crying or anything
like that what they have technology to
that you could jump off the analytic
next when they could just you can just
preserve the brain I felt they can build
over that's true yeah yeah and they have
opposite clubs device you keep on you
all the time so keep all that backs
y'all
well no the one you know get you out of
trouble based on some drone will come by
and took care draw a little
communicators
yeah yeah exactly
somewhere was umbrella generally pull
any discarded planet other than
eyeshadow you have the neural net that
microscopically intertwined with your
whole brain
yeah it just gonna load you down the
molecule so let's look at that are you
yeah all the folks on the mainland all
this so that's a good time you could see
the talk I do like it's about
philosophical sensitive what is your
personal identity does remind me of a
different series where they had a very
check of your brain but obviously the
you'd still die just a copy if you would
live home and not to spoil the series
that answered the protagonist facing his
own doesn't really think he's actually
going to die he meets his copy and it's
kind of a bittersweet all I remember who
wrote it and it wasn't them because it's
all different characteristics it looks
so there's this um there's this
audiobook and listening to right now
call them we are legion we are Baba
enough everyone helps good fantastic
it's like a sort of comedy-drama science
fiction that's amazing about this guy
who who sells as Internet company in our
time and makes like six hundred million
dollars and lives almost crazy stuff and
one of the
does what signed up with this company
that will cut off the pad when he dies
and frees us and I want reading the
whole book because we're only beginning
turned on then goes to Vegas to a sci-fi
conference we get hit by Connor
and the Hobbit pad and freezes he wakes
up
17 years later but the problem is that a
snow can't be stuck here revived its
brain brain is just a puddle on the
floor and they scan the computer instead
and they have several backup copies of
him and the mainframe gets destroyed and
then he gets rebooted and he's like well
well what am i what you like seem like a
smooth series of events but yeah I mean
there's other things that come up in
other series or like laughs it seems to
be ongoing lately and the black mirror
series on Netflix about fertilizer and
it's Angela parallel huh yeah well
that's interesting it's interesting if
you replace yourself all at once within
AI is that you what is no doubt a little
bit about if you replace you sound a
little bit at a time
looks like the old AI think about the
broom ALS efficacy see an orphan black
looks a little differently - yeah well
he's a clone but it's different people
yeah the question is how much there's
two questions how much does environment
deflect it and then where is free will
that area look those type of the second
thing with an invaluable oh yeah oh yeah
the call me so when we even ask why did
you write the culture series and why is
that the shape that it has he said it
was in reaction to a lot of the science
I was reading at the time that is kind
of common people like you know I'm not
happy with what what there is all do my
own thing the British stuff seemed
mostly miserable lists and the u.s. is
to right-wing I want to say that I
combined what I'd regard as the best
book but a thoughtfulness and sense of
proportion of uk's and the energy and
optimism of
u.s. grin so that's an interesting mix
right there so the way the culture came
about initially was as I thought at the
time singly solution to particular
problem I was getting ready to write use
of weapons and I knew that like always
was this sort of Ultimate Warrior guy
but I want him to be prophesied the good
guys somehow so I came up with the idea
that cultures as ultimate employers
they're the good guys but they employ
this guy who's kind of a bad guy why
because they they need him to do
something here it's dirty but justified
at work and that's one of the key themes
that runs throughout these mouths you
know this question of what's what's
actually justified is the ethical
concerns so he says that was it
initially but then the culture proved to
be the nucleus around which all my other
work until then rather nebulous ideas
during a cluster and takes shape and it
developed naturally I felt by itself
from there well then in the next passage
after the Lord are you ever going to be
done in this I said God you know I mean
think about it
once you create something when things
keep on making Rowland more and more so
I said I decided right from the start to
resist the temptation to tear it all
down at any point and this has become
sort of indicative and symbolic of the
nature and demeanor of the culture
itself it means to resist completion and
put off sublime to be sort of a rocky
and rise in to a higher level so that it
can keep on going sticking around in the
real and trying to do good as a visa for
as long as it can and it's already in
visit envisaging that when it finally
does fade away it will it'll be when
it's going will hardly be noticed
because being something like the culture
will be pretty much the default state
for all Galactic Civilizations
and they said like fine I keep getting
trashed by finding new things to write
about sometimes these come from
brand-new ideas and it gives a few
examples of that and then sometimes it
comes from charoli ideas single words
and run on you know and it gives
examples the air sphere is mentioned in
fleebus turning up and
to windward there's I mean if you think
about it booked this long there's
probably stuff you could mind in here
for decades afterwards right that's
pretty ingenious it shows you some of
his his what would you call it is
planning that's involved in this you
know we've used this this distinction
that comes with in fantasy literature
between architects and gardeners that
with Tolkien being sort of the paradigm
of an architect somebody you have
planned everything out has whole
storyboards in dense languages as well
who else would you put it then yeah
somebody else will be we did recently
though where they created whole like
descriptions of but almost like
anthropological stuff loads of it'll
McCaffrey did that yeah that's right
yeah the gardener's they plant stuff and
you know there's there's something
actually there but then they see what
happens with it and sometimes it like
chokes off the other plants sometimes
they have to weed it sometimes it blooms
well and George RR Martin's an example
of that he didn't actually know when he
was somebody's doing things just top
things are going to turn out least
sometimes pleasantly or unpleasantly
surprised as we as readers debatable
whether he actually completely knows
where the solid ice and fires doing you
know exactly does like you know we don't
know until it comes out yeah interesting
you thought at the time us science
fiction's to right-wing because on this
side the pond people thought is to left
blank
well had Star Trek weathers you have
white man kissing a black hole man you
don't know what a black woman is an
officer on a starship and you have that
was all seen as pretty radically and so
we're looking at relationship the 80s
yes the circuit world began in the 60s
yeah we've been plagued by them you've
got space operas Battlestar Galactica
which is look that's formal on time that
much later
right okay for the manual Battlestar
Galactica the original Battlestar
Galactica was yeah London seventies no
Buck Rogers you know oh yeah those are
just shows then we'd have to think about
like who's who's on the scene and
returning books out in the river stuff
yeah I mean Anna Boch wasn't super
productive by that hymen was highly was
lecturing about Apple books a year what
would you call it yeah who else in
America was really crazy stuff out what
there was writing in the 77086 87
eighties
then I remember there being a lot of
sort of like one-off kind of not very
carefully response all read the past a
lot of the stuff that we're reading it
than with me like in the fifties and
again when X news type they did attend
to it yeah the Catherine is running
heavily in the seventies yeah Andrew
Norton was writing heavily Sade's Lackey
okay
Marion Zimmer Bradley Ursula Queens
yeah they were already and they're
already different around true in
philosophy they're all pretty
yeah they're not very white women
right-wing libertarian certain like
hardliners military side by 5
yes
he was talking about Nelson which the
author but what would within evil the
content I have every socialist I'll go
about killing aliens for being weird
Malik's are a lot over the neighborhood
what would have done in there around
that time my Volvo was writing a lot of
stuff their stuff is a lot of like let's
shoot the aliens yeah yeah was it one
now when photos turned to be more like
something like like animal science will
were predominantly stupid masses out
there you know keep them away from the
ship before they wreck at all a little
thanks they'd lay their own Starship
Troopers was written around that time
yeah every weird with the most hardline
tools the tide of yeah he was late
fifties mid 60 16 yeah stranger in a
strange land 61 is why I got back now
you know where the route bill just run
another way yeah we're good into this
jungle well then I'm confused by a
couple things because I and what you
know the gardener tends his garden is
the gardener altruistic Oh in written
with reference to the culture series no
he says coke is self-consciously
altruistic yeah I don't you know I
didn't really I saw their
self-perception as being altruistic but
as other actions as being well little
dedicated and imperialism yeah you live
in here is here's our perception all
right we'll help you get there
well we called on what do we call
paternalist
I'm really keen you ask why do that it's
viewed as and in their viewing it like I
said is altruistic
because they know what's really good for
these people over there you know like
for example in player of games writers
was weird civilization and very
stratified everything's got their plays
totally unlike the culture right and so
they didn't fix that maybe that's it
that's where all three changes to
paternalism what yeah the person is
being paternalistic probably sees them
but self is altruistic yeah yeah
while under way word is family you've
got a caste system yes the culture
decides that they can make it better and
fix it manda creating the civil war
yeah and nearly letting people get
killed others wonder if there's ever any
true alterable chosen is it is there
really anything that you're not getting
something from on some level that
there's true you know I thought about
that for a very long time is this based
on perception yeah there's a book of Job
years and years ago 70 Robert winger
looking out for number one
Oh a loss of he was there is no such
thing as to rupture that that's that's
what everybody's out to get something
and it drives me it might be what you're
out to get is what you are right now and
you're all at your how you can take on
that everybody's out of certain point
that there weren't look getting into
here and you can push it far enough
here's the stretch it's of that length
the good of the other person layer
you're clearly striving for it becomes
what year you're really about the warm
fuzzy or there's something like that and
you can see they're not common cases but
you do see cases where people behave in
very altruistic ways fun may not be
perfectly altruistic but that doesn't
mean that there isn't any altruism but
when you create a civil war in an entire
society all you want to call yourself
altruistic yeah well pretend I mean gets
a bad rap are you the community yeah
yeah I think because it's not what you
would think
yeah medicine used to be paternalistic I
have it still lives sometimes if it's
not you can either have paternalistic
medicine which is wearing what your dad
here yeah this is what you should do and
that's the end of it and you are really
sick and you're going to die
shouldn't do any of this stuff and
things didn't cost much and people
didn't suffer needlessly or you can have
the lawyers and the businesspeople room
it yeah it may come on to get our
stations on because rather than a
cluster and and that I would say
providing the ideal outcomes you think
that there's still there's still some
areas within American medicine where
it's still wind up being paternalistic
think we have to make sure you identify
and what is it a like tribute on the
emergency room triage area and Sarah
some old horsemen out there he wasn't
ever take exception that because I
wouldn't say the best because I wanted a
doctor to a paternalistic by character
who were obnoxious right well we're
gonna have to here overweight another
thing another you maybe in some ways
better than what we have as you can see
how it got ruined we can make a
distinction there though between link
paternalistic because they really get a
kick out of like telling people what to
do and then paternalistic because
they're they you know they're they're
placed into a circumstance where they
realize I'm the only person who actually
doesn't know what's going on I think it
was the longer very different the longer
it sits the more paternalistic and
becomes that because I about unit I can
mean it again and again and again and
people want to know what he would do if
you're in that situation they don't want
to be told
okay well we could do this or we could
do this yeah are we to do this so what
do you want to do yeah yeah you know
I'll say something similar to that came
up in in my experience in the academic
administration and I never thought it
would happen because you know I thought
all my peers are rational shoes and so
you you know I got involved in the thing
they actually got started turned out as
good at writing reports so like they
came to the attention of Dean really
like when we need to do a project we're
going to bring this guy in on it and
gradually I wound up with more and more
who's that one of my previous positions
more and more tiles and and duties and a
lot of committees and I have we've
entered in with this sort of notion like
well everybody's rational will get
things done and it very quickly became
clear to me that a lot of my colleagues
who are smart people that they'd sit
around a table like this and like their
brains are fall good luck yeah and you'd
be like okay so you know we have to
figure out what we're going to do to
answer the assessor's it also that the
school can stay open and we can get
federal funding what are we going to do
and they get off you know maybe we
should you know and after a certain
point you're like alright fine
here's what you gonna do exactly because
um and you do it like out of frustration
in a recession a budget on the table
there even these hyper-intelligent
shit's mine basically have that argument
for five chapters a little eautiful yeah
is acne going to recently forget the
affront asan how the culture very you
can kind of feel them for holding
themselves back from interfering
Camila's this utilitarian sinkhole where
if the environment is designed to cause
maximum suffering could be offenders or
say this basically well and the cultural
drug and filters like this feels really
wrong but I can't say anything and yeah
it's kind of interesting so here I was
like maybe they could have interceded a
little more yeah it's a very brutal
species and they just kind of watch them
do what they do but the the other
element the actual accession of thing
and as the pot is around all these these
ships that have the mines
of an entire planet behind them ya know
the six or seven of them they can't
figure out what to do about this and
they do that the world we we should try
this they will do that they threw their
moderator out for being a little too
paternal yeah another one of the mines
yeah yeah he's sort of controlling the
one so she interesting times game yeah
and then oh one of the mines has been
really annoying so they start in modern
terms a new shaft and walk him out of
the chat room so they can proceed with
business
so let's actually talk about that seeing
that play out mines and what I got hmm
yeah I mean they're they're hyper
intelligent they're almost like godlike
status but not not of course worshipped
as gods truly intriguing idea and it you
know from a narrative perspective it
lets you cut out a lot of problems it
was one of the classic issues in sci-fi
you don't want explain how hyperdrives
worker is answering similarly in
explaining how society functions you
don't explain too much because that one
you get it can be very boring to the
reader and on the other hand if you do
make it explicit there's going to be
somebody is going to say that's about
science or so that a Mike what do you
make of this notion of these super
intelligent AI beings that at the same
time don't take over their banana forest
equipment well they're designed that way
right that's that's part of that sort of
built into it almost sort of like you
know and the mocking a lot of fun today
Roger robotics right look to windward to
furrow the drum to furrow is very
hedonistic just like the humans he
wonders if they're done hedonistic drove
a sadistic drama in player games awesome
he devised all-out realistic use it was
are the right those are just wrong those
are in a lower level we're like up their
smocks
for about 11 seconds yeah pretty Ariane
succeeded yeah
well I need to do hot yeah I can't
recall which book talked about it and
maybe want to remember I think there was
even a discussion amongst the mind
someone else tonight
I might even hang out with all of these
why are you mommy
yeah well why are you slumming and I one
of the points was well if they're kind
of like me pets and others were like oh
no it's a little more involved in that
here call the exact same but I find it
interesting and weren't interesting they
would go do something an exception at
one point like there's been either time
an infinite fun space doing mathematical
program do whatever here and they kind
of begrudgingly have to protect surface
reality because of surface reality is
wiped out or something thank you around
anymore
so it's kind of like there's a you know
there's a with that what does reminds me
of if there's a really interesting
argument that was made in ancient
philosophy by the Epicureans and the
immaterial you know they get known for
like being materialist when they're all
about pleasure and stuff like that and
usually there seems to maintenance but
actually they did believe that there
were gods and what was funny about what
they thought about the gods with the
gods had nothing to do whatsoever with
which human fares the universe because
if they did it wouldn't be happy the
gods are blessed and they blessed
precisely because they stayed a hell out
of every bit of business what could
possibly can you know well the mind
could have done that right things that
don't bother us with your your your
nonsense you know we were treated appear
mathematics or something like that
one of us messiness what is caring about
human beings yeah I think they like the
messiness
well there is where gift interest so the
messiness of human beings could provide
an additional channel that sector
mathematics wouldn't you know like an
exception to that when I find out that
someone's going ahead and doing
something without talking about it well
wait and but we can't so at least they
don't they don't go from paternalism to
the add realism I mean they could have
they could have stopped them I mean you
know what we let me shift the topic a
little bit of the first thing is let me
ask all of you so if we could have a
society that was run by you know all the
logistics are handled by these gigantic
a is that have all figured out and it is
yet its I to me where we end up getting
screwed over it's not less or turned
into like a matrix turn into batteries
or anything like yeah but they're really
going to try to make our lives great
with would you would you pick that sort
of thing I think I probably guarantee
Devas are presented what would you care
passionately with an off-switch believe
I can do it's the wonderful staff which
is being the other yeah sooner or later
they give you out how that you had to
say well they are well you know I like I
said just a couple times before I still
see AI is the next step in our evolution
I just do you know at some point we are
going to look at the download we are you
know our consciousness it is going to be
you know we're no longer amoebas that we
keep moving and I just kind of see that
down the road we are not going to have
as much relevance when we start doing
when you start getting things like that
what is going to be our purpose at some
point they're going to have we're going
to stop reproducing because I think
we're going to work your way out and
this will be the next step toward gods
or whatever you think the purpose of
being here is
um but I I just had I guess there's as I
start reading kurtzweil all logistical
and I just started thinking some some
reason I just feel that's going to be
the eventual evolutionary step would you
miss to having let's say that actually
does happen would you miss having a body
and the sort of bodily experiences I
won't agree to know I mean I'm not to be
around it but what is you know or
feeling you know that you know if you
evolve be to that point you probably I
mean that I would say that is you know
something that's evolved from whatever
to human do they miss you you don't know
be picture somewhere else know what
every neuron into a sensor that lets you
sense things we couldn't even imagine
because the like I mean would be a blank
space you're going into a virtual
reality reality it's sort of a different
reality and I thought I think you lose
you think of bridge the way out of your
3d immersion differently even five years
from now or ten years from now as it
relates to people watching football
protocol or whatever
my theory is all these stadiums are
building will be empty in ten years or
certainly before they're 30 years and
their mortgages come to because a
younger generation will be so immersed
in the technology and that experience
may be the same gameplay in whatever but
that will become more real maybe sex
will become more artificial real the
same thing to so that that will become
more engaging that the endorphins and
everything
producing in the brain so they will look
at them well why go through and sit in a
cold Stadium and and distant and yeah
I'm in the field I'm a bear right of a
there are a lot of years I'm in Aaron
Rodgers being or whatever rather than so
I get more yeah engaging that they lose
touch just like the bread yeah you know
they lose at with it and somebody says
no the real thing is the sweat and the
cold and the agony and the joy and the
you detach from that because it's more
convenient drilling but on the other
hand you know from the other point of
view but if you is to throw on VR
goggles and you play with Aaron Rodgers
you're playing your video game it's
perceptibly similar to be watching it
from the stadium just a warm Rainier
here well then that will overtake that
will become the norm and the throw on
the more engaging valuable participator
engagement not going to the game and
making on read it this well answer your
question I think I wouldn't if I was
having a choice right not to go and he'd
be downloaded into a machine yes I would
miss my body where I am NOT yeah do I
miss being a frog at one point no you
know because at one point we have been
all these things so but we haven't
evolved beyond fellas let me change the
question that look at things I like when
we talk about the river world once you
could have your 20 year old bottle oh
you bet and you all kinds of different
goods I think your question that you
posed about 10 minutes ago um if you go
back to you know wouldn't you be enticed
you know for this law called benevolent
paternalism
but that hasn't autocratic you give back
you're guaranteed yeah I think you know
what would the German people thinking in
in 1938 about their situation
along with coming this you know this
autocratic but promising you are
superior and we're going to get the
boogeyman and whatever we're going to do
something and I think they were giving
up something because they were going to
get this better thing that they were do
or told they were do but in other cases
it's more benevolent and but it gets
back to the guarantee and wanted to get
twisted and they're always couch
cautious yeah I mean but don't you think
even today this drive for security and
giving up what we would otherwise call
you know you you know you know you know
something I know our privacy our rights
our freedom but people are willing to
make that trade up when they get afraid
enough but it's been the Frog in the pot
it's been one degree it you know one
degree on here again if we step back to
nineteen fifty forty five sixty people
had a belief in America I believe that
if they're looking up for us this is my
government I have ownership of it it's
forming was opposed to as corporate
perception knows no it's it's a
different perception completely you know
I thought died for my country now I'm
not bad for corporations man I remember
having a conversation with a wiser grad
student this older professor and he was
he was you know Oliver Stone's like you
know stuff was coming out about Kennedy
and he is so important that's like why
and he is like well you know you know
you start talking about all these
conspiracy theories and I was like I'm
not really that interested in that why
do you care about this you're here a
philosophy professor well you know if
Lindsey happened in this happened this
happened that proves that the government
was corrupt and I looked at this like
well who the hell doesn't know they yeah
and I'm realized the pulse between his
generation and minds you know when when
like people are like well where were you
when this happened because there was
that loss or what's called like a loss
of innocence or some thank you whereas
if you grew up you know in the 70s and
80s oh there's the time they did wake
guy and every nap there was no yeah
child crimes so no well there was
they're looking at your face yeah it
wasn't reported there is actually more
child prime Gator in the real yes yeah
and what is the news what does it say
already was lower it is yeah yeah but if
you would listen to nothing but the news
gonna say yeah yeah your pop which is
your equation but dr henry internal
whole series of that vr the golden river
eye shadow the shadow lens but it's a
channel my for book series gets a fourth
very very slow shadow and it's based on
a child
it gets immersed into the VR and it's a
brain connection and you live in the vr
a little drunk a second yeah it's a
reality so there's there's an ulterior
motive decision will do it but you live
it if you die in the VR you die okay and
if you're in the VR you never come out
your body your real body stars to death
so there is ricotta neo there Gibson's
stuff was like that too right you know
here's yeah yeah we're to look at some
of those the same sort of thing where
you die in there but the VR is that real
yeah and so here's another sort of
related question I mean where we are
right now we can see that robotics is
just you know getting involved in all
these different wings you are close to
having not just driving those cars but
driverless semi trucks that will be
carrying a lot more Freight pudding
truckers are business after a while a I
getting more and more
okay to retain my like in Hollands
medical things we're probably going to
see in our lifetime some pretty massive
unemployment until the question or if
you have other things farmed out to AI
so that I guess the question is well if
we have to have a active we want things
are like these Minds where they are
pretty thin at once or you know what's
the alternative
who's going to build them well you know
a certain point to become self
militarily look at alter is not
something really yeah well you know
controlling and making sure that you
control the situation also coated yeah
yellow yes well you know I mean I
remember what I have a friend of his
guns on computer country he he went to
one semester of college dropped out and
started serving but after high school
and I remember when he was you know two
decades ago he was telling me about
learning c-plus and he was really
excited about it because I'm like
working with you know machine language
or Doss or anything like that where
you're telling you what to do you're
telling the computer is that kind of
code himself and I was started that
stuff and now work like your school yeah
so a lot of this is going to be you know
the eight or seven core code you're not
writing your AI program and yeah under
all your taking bits and pieces from all
these different places but how much of
the code do we actually understand it
can employ well that's the problem is
that kind of lost control of that yeah I
mean how you remember back when we had
you know computers are very from current
perspective July promise infant I'm okay
oh yeah how easy was to like keep track
of what what was going on because
programs are only like you know I'm in
line blah
yeah you could write pong yeah one your
Commodore 64 how it is human being keep
all of that in their head what's
that's what they don't they have said
job as they pull in from other areas
that exciting - yeah I'm going to do
this but that means there's nobody I'll
get an overall grasp of the system right
hmm well you've got a replicator some
you got your outlines plan yeah then you
find ways to do it
in wouldn't it'll be right now so blame
should just be easier to have some super
sophisticated computer that could
monitor all that sort of stuff you know
when they look back to guaranty and
which is wrong test and waiting for the
malfunctions and the you know the
corruption yeah wherever it comes from
even within the culture the hope is that
the AI that we created would be but I
will do it with the head well would
think differently would think
differently must because if we were the
AI that we created yeah and it was some
other lower form of life that created us
we don't know what had happened to them
so if we did ordered with that being
that there were the ones that are
creating it if they're created in our
image I think no N word they talk about
the culture has a board of humans that
oversee what the bonds are doing and
what the hub is doing and the stated
purpose is to make sure that that's
alludes to country the AI don't go too
far there's one during the track there's
one character in considered flemeth's
who's supposed to be able to understand
which is like one of 30 and a few Minh
in the entire universe who can
understand what the minds are doing as
well so I suppose that would be
and I'll go any what some I start wiping
about if you choose an AI the value of
life
oh the a la that made it yeah then
there's you've got a sort of one step
that no background right how does that
ia I get it you'd have to in some way of
somehow modeling that you know it's
interesting in there there was a it's
not the same issue but there's a similar
issue that came up in this series of
science fiction stories they were these
about these like jag antic pinks I think
they're called bolos and they've slept
alone were like a mile long and what
they what they started doing with them
is giving them pain receptors so when
they start getting a lot of damage
they'd actually like starts to care is
I'm supposed like a little dot because
they're sticking it up and then of
course
bolos fairly quickly realize that this
is a terrible dictator subject they
start you know exudative a certain scape
their programming and all that what you
didn't do would be almost like the
opposite of that where somehow you would
give them the ability to feel pleasure I
don't know how much infants pleasure
some sort of satisfaction like all the
things being the way that should be when
human beings are Rebecca higness we have
done that but I mean why do you think in
this event and he knows it was fairly
easy to model like if you think about
you want to make a human society right
and have a machine to run it well if you
into him like a he'd missed ik model for
how the society ought to run that's
pretty simple like get get people
surveys every once in a while you know
where things could just look in their
brain centers and see what the pleasure
centers are lighting off and you know as
opposed to painters you can do that
serve utilitarian calculation when it
comes to like you know higher valency
yes we've got a humility blonde to make
the most people happy yeah we're going
to destroy North America to free up that
how do you do that
one of the cameras down but it is your
machine self-conscious or not well these
are sharp there was a recent Doctor Who
episode the new season yeah where
they're at a planet that was established
just as utopian human community and the
robots were programmed a I was
programmed that they need to keep people
happy
the idea was to be happy yeah someone
dies and someone greed well they're not
happy so nobody can diagnose and they
start killing people off because they're
not happy and there is a mere
programming is to keep people happy with
those weirdos and I end up wiping out
the entire colony the roads the other AI
does yeah because they can't compute the
grief amazing thing they're looking down
here there are you paying to make people
happy to give utilitarian calculation
yes yeah do calculate they calculate say
well our goal is to keep people happy
there's a magic turning partly she
happens are those sort of stories to
them they're points the fact that there
has to be some sort of governing factor
where once cuz other like the risk is an
AI like it everything fits its model
that's alright now I'm going to do this
and it's such a feedback loop right so
like the one that you're talking about
everybody's going to kill off that makes
people unhappy got children some more
until there's nothing left there
I get it I suppose that's something
that's that's part of the way we humans
work is we have these other things that
come in and say hey knock it off dummy
you know take a step back and look at
what that holds going on here and that
can sometimes be our own you know soft
regulation but a lot of times as other
people can intervening and saying what
the hell are you doing here societal
pressures yeah the worms got hit and hit
others when you were younger you realize
the consequences so yeah all of that
went into building filling us up but if
you just count turning you on
I get why hockings is scary
well maybe in this case maybe they're
not just turned on right away right they
go through a bunch of trial stuff I mean
if I can turn this one is well there's a
drone right and he wants to work for
contact special circumstances with
contact of the military arm special
circumstances is like military
intelligence and he turns out to be a
real jerk - nobody wants to work with
they kick them out
and you know maybe there's something
like that for the way we and the culture
want to replace their self that's what I
want to just injected by inventing a tie
what is it that what is his desire to
replace or somebody's convenient
ourselves I think it's make a lot easier
we're not playing yourself there's a
moment to gradually I mean it's a I am
an artificial limb oh I know I mean but
it goes down to one of those things just
because your kid you can't should you I
mean money ever well I understand you
know like the mechanization and doing
things for like robotics and things but
when you're actually talking about an
intelligent being to replace what humans
as a human and not not as working as a
machine or anything else or to actually
replace yourself what is the pregnancy
the purpose replace yourself
oh yeah just sign well okay look if I
give it a polite where's purpose of
Earth in the universe we are limited now
human beings to her so what is the
purpose of Earth in the grand scheme of
the universe does it have any or is it
just a speck
irrelevant and we're ascribing too much
purpose to our own horse ourselves as if
we're controlling something beyond the
river oh yeah - go back to your question
of why
was broaden wide technology right so
back in ancient Greeks Aristotle
observed he he called slaves and sold
tools right and when we go to some very
nice right those you flip it on its side
she talks about you know a lot we
wouldn't need slaves if we had you know
looms were the shuttle rolled itself and
then people would have to do these
crappy jobs we wouldn't have to have
these power dynamics where one person is
in charge the other person is stock
doing as a controller and so that's one
of the big dreams of technology is that
it will liberate human beings from
oppressive power relations now it
usually doesn't turn out to be so pretty
maybe we try to do what they're doing
arrows Avengers sitting around you have
no purpose you have no useful man why
are you here
yeah that's another point here your
grandma boxer from resources because
they're really mean here's a culture I
mean here's the thing if let's say we
actually let's say it working right and
we freed everything up and we did it
with the people that we are today so
let's say it's contemporary America and
boom the technology takes off and let's
even say that like Apple and Google and
Microsoft you know and Amazon are
driving it but suddenly each of their
you know CEOs and even the shareholders
suddenly going to wild here and they're
like let's do this for the public good
and so we're just sort of dreaming here
now what would we do with their time I
know I would I would certainly have no
problem filling up my house how how
would you get money to buy any weather
block or book so that's less effect this
is a post-scarcity society you don't
show the way they set up everything you
want gets gets provided I'm talking can
I meet one more well we just went did it
well how I mean one thing I mean it's
like if you don't know utopia yeah look
around you I mean 100 year
this is utopia 10 years ago people would
say I could only not die if I don't have
any choice yes and just go in this hour
and a faucet I work 40 hours a week all
the monies every day every day as I work
that would never be unhappy for longer
live but not everyone in the world has
or not everybody brohamer sighs well
there are lots of playful opening to
have water
true fine Electra my fans we still
aren't letters stop we're so Alec okay
well Cameron our done yeah was thinking
you twenty years we could and this is a
real possibility it's been written about
three different people have listened to
the books on the jobless economy we're
real civil Nymeria it'll be a job to
come so then the big deal like when
their goat sitting in Davos they're not
talking about Dec another time but what
the hell did you do all these people cuz
I don't mean oh no way for them to earn
any money and government this is not
going to pour stuff on you when there's
nobody's paying taxes because there's no
money there we give you so much there's
so much resources and wealth and
everything is knowledge although that's
also one with the order alarms are you
know what I need anymore if you really
look at that if you did not have a
science fiction writer or something
that's a real person that is they're all
reality here and tell them what are we
going to do in an unemployment forty
percent is probably get higher than we
are a scarcity society yeah you know one
so there's a couple different answers
that one is that we're all going to
become artisans yeah that that is wrong
like you know can be calm
we've code you sure he'll you know cut
your special way no actually was
actually what they've outfit I don't I
don't see that I don't see how that's
gonna happen you know because you'd
still have to have money exchanging
hands somehow music changing barter and
good I mean really to play the culture
would look over as
the Andromeda galaxy and be like oh it's
basically as well photography right yeah
I've got everything what we want
please look over there and say well all
that what would you like to have that -
you know what you know it's interesting
because then in philippi dicks some of
his stories this is where they're
colonizing other either either would
have a new planetary system or or other
planetary systems there's this contrast
drawn between like the colonies where
life has meaning and stuff like that and
then crappy earth where these people are
left like a laborer is like that the
average Dream of Electric Sheep people
are left behind struggle with depression
and all the you know that the buildings
are all to get banned in so there's this
you hear with the sound and nobody being
there and that gets some people driving
up so it could be a solution you know go
out and certainly on that thing at the
solution I'm just saying it's what we do
you know it's what we're going after new
frontiers there's all I wanted it's not
like we're to sit here now a common
matter let's go on this all day yeah are
we cut it right I would I wouldn't
that's another big cone yeah
maybe if I did it for a year I'd be like
this is crap yeah thanks have a series
we're going to create a some UNIX we
want to repair all your DNA so that you
live the 500 we can't do that we have to
create something that can do it that's
going to do it well there's organs I
mean there's growing organs and things
now being 10 years they're going to be
go try and replace your brain your brain
is a thing that's this can hold in
things back you can have all the rest be
working pretty good rip debris yeah
rewires with 3d characters they are they
are there no I mean their project really
marketable I've been sitting in trees he
had the club civilization wide version
of permanently gone fishing which is the
subliminal oh yeah and read interesting
cuz then the culture is consciously
choosing to keep working in the real
world rather retiring but obviously he
doesn't talk much about the civilization
a mystery books I read yeah he finally
does talk about it in his in the last
book by doing about it
it's very good company I know I know and
the funny thing is what else resonating
he very briefly talks about how a very
rare few people have come back from the
subliming and nobody's come back saying
oh it's awful don't do it they're all
agreed it's pretty cool so but they
didn't say why
oh did you see what their motives for
coming guys huh just a chicken carry
anything okay there's getting sober once
a while and I think the other thing that
the other side you find purpose by
joining contact and then you've got like
adventures to go on you'd like to kill
you know you have to experience hardship
and all that well the context this is
one of the other things I didn't want to
talk about so if we have a utopia like
this they still need some people to get
their hands dirty and to like beer a
little buffer from the you know the
other named empires or yeah learning on
interfere with things and then you've
got this you know special circumstances
or even even you know more into that
sort of thing
and that seems like a way which people
could camp renewed meaning in their life
a lot of weather a lot of other
characters when it sort of working for
them they're not actually part of the
culture that they end up working for
them or they work for people who that
are against the culture
and these are problems don't occur to
them you know it's really interesting
because in the first one the main
character she he's working for the enemy
the enemy civilization that's actually
beating the culture at the start and
he's doing it because he doesn't like
what the culture stands for but he gives
a lot of you know there's quite a few
arguments and monologues in thing about
what's wrong that kind of society he's
using alternative and one well you know
the L trick is very doctoring if you
know it's a it's these cute them you
know sort of like battle crazy people
yeah there's like cultural event
yeah well oftentimes our alternatives
are not between two ideals in the
funders we look to windward is
especially fun to read because you spend
a lot of time on a normal following like
the life of what it's like there and
it's pretty nice well I Danielle again
is we've got unlimited resource yeah but
they don't even think of it like that
they don't even think of it like
unlimited resources they I think that it
would be completely idiom for them to
think like I'm Annette lobster all the
time they just they seem to enjoy just
being that much really being to excess
yeah but just like enjoying well it
seemed like a like symphony yeah that
any arguing some creative creative some
sports it well you need the other thing
too is they're they're all growing out
there environment that renders them
better adjusted without the sort of
child
traumas or whatever we have to work
through software from well in accession
one of the drones spends 100 years
working on a sand filter well the idea
is why not yeah there's no purpose he
just wanted to do it their relative you
think about it would have to be like
some as you're doing a moment-to-moment
there must be some enjoyment oh yeah how
this is not how that's happening yeah
one of the other things that came off of
it was the genetic enhancement I mean if
we're talking about in terms of like our
society and what we're going to do with
you know massive unemployment the
probably don't want because we don't
want more people around long but but in
a society like this they're they're
modifying human genome to do all sorts
of cool crazy stuff like the capacity
for example to produce your own drugs in
your head and then we good instead of
lay about getting high it's about like
being you know you know that you need
something to tell you about a drought if
we could produce adrenaline whatever we
needed it just concentration yeah what
would we do it you know if we if we knew
that we had certain things that would
make us more attentive and let's say
listening to a symphony would we I don't
do that because I my mind wanders all
time I do I use it reading - yeah and I
don't think that
[Music]
you
[Music]